hello you stupid babies but don't worry
stupid babies need the most attention
I'm such a girl right that's just her
Danielle Dan we're here to talk about
speed hopefully you've just seen the
honest trailer for speed we're gonna
talk about our thought process and start
every video like that it doesn't matter
what you and if you end there'll be some
deleted scenes that didn't make it into
the final cut of speed in my opinion a
great film yep yeah as far as action
movies go it is all I want nothing more
nothing less
it is of its time Oh easily brilliantly
along with the rock and Conair and a few
others just like it could never been
made any time but in the mid-90s no like
a mid budget very simple constraint
present that premise
I remember Lana's saying like if this
were made today like the entire world
would somehow be at stake if the bus
blew up
yes just like 12 people if we like the
bus going to the UN or something
definitely someone on a computer like
remotely helping what other modern
tropes can we throw in a bowl yeah he's
working with someone on the inside
so like Jeff Daniels or somebody would
have been a traitor there were actually
that was originally in the script really
somebody I think it was Jeff Dale's or
somebody is like somebody you thought
was dead turns out to be the guy and
what's his name was just word pain
Howard pain was just was working with
him he was like a stepstool it would
have been a cover for something it would
have been a distraction to cover up the
real crime like there would have been 14
layers of complication attitude and said
the real crime is that someone has taken
control of the world's weather
satellites yes and they would have built
into the premise that this was going to
expand to the boat universe rather than
just being caught flat-footed and be
like well [ __ ]
my head went to Russell Brand we thought
speed that bus goes really fast it's
very it's a charming movie like I you
know it's not
it isn't trying to be what it's not
there's a bus you guys so you gotta stop
the bus
there's no don't stop the bus you gotta
you got it where you gonna stop the bomb
on the bus it's not it doesn't want to
be anything else it's not trying to sell
me something which I guess I've also
gotten used to there's not like product
placement or anything I'm not like
speeding by billboards for coke first we
were discussing so my first rated-r
movies yes I was a legend when this
movie came out I was on a very strict no
r-rated movies regiment mmm there on his
friends one of the ones that my mom
watched and declared okay for him
awesome consume as I was growing lad and
so I have dirty words yeah this is my
first rated R movie this is one of my
first VHS tapes watched it all the time
yeah you know we always going down the
elevators like tomokawa took this job
about cheap gold watch and she goes cool
that we set all the time like dismissive
late like and then when I saw John
Oliver do it for the first time on last
weekend tonight when he goes cool into
the camera we're like oh my god a key
honor do you think that was a speed of
cool cuz I need all the time yeah
now it's Canon for me that it's just
that he's that much of a speed fan yeah
cool he's thinking of speed oh yeah just
like me let's watch our honest trailer
for speed
this summer we're getting honest about
summer blockbusters past and present
this you guys that's fine you can start
a lot of trailers of each other under a
trenchcoat and for editors Verdi can
measure shot speed
somewhere in Los Angeles there's a bomb
on a bus and if it slows down it will
explode exactly yes it's not that
complicated romantic you know we know
that wild cat behind the wheel not to
slow down in the hold speed we get it
okay moving on
I think the simplicity of the movie that
was the trade office you do need to
under under Lion and every five minutes
just how seriously it vital it is that
this bus not slow down below 50 despite
the fact they clearly forgot it yeah I
mean for this guy's mo it's like
actually a pretty complicated bombing
plot compared to his last one and the
elevators which was just like give me
the money or I'll blow up this elevator
this one's kind of like it relies on a
lot of guesswork and luck and people
being on the bus took us a shorter
amount of time to plan right actually
yeah he he throws out some line like
that
took me years and then it's like maybe a
month later editing my thought is this
one this one's completely personal this
one's not actually about the money he's
very mad at Keanu Reeves and revenge can
motivate you to do some quick thinking
yeah I mean it's clearly not about about
the money because he blows up his own
house yeah I assume Southern California
96 like he could have gotten a I mean
this movie does suffer from 90s
deflation where he's thinking three
million dollars he was very upset with
that dye pack blew up though yeah that's
completely Beverly but just sell the
house but yeah this is definitely not a
movie where a key piece of information
is told to you like in a Fellowship of
the Ring way and then the character
superimposes and says it again in a key
moment at the end hmm this is a movie
where someone just says it out loud
every other sentence yeah yeah
appreciate and respect that mm-hmm I
appreciate that
I respect ignite it
meet la cop Jack Traven
he's young dumb and full of gum
hopefully you got that might break
reference Jack and his partner may be
the Dumber halves of their comedy duo's
buzz nearness we just weak we just we
discuss this more than you think
yep were Keanu and Jeff Daniels the
Dumber of the two dumb do it well then
we discussed that there's multiple types
of intelligence yes EQ but just you know
colloquially I think that Ted is the
Dumber one of Bill and Ted and Harry and
Lloyd Harry Lloyd is how Lloyd is so
dumb I put boy I put Lloyd a little
ahead because he's driven and focused
and he made his plans are not good but
he at least knows like what a plan is
and maybe to have one where Harry just
drifts and is and poops up
Lloyd's great plan yeah that's true
Lloyd did that's sure Lloyd this is a
plan that's true plotter I'd like it or
not here he's just the sheepdog you know
trot along next to him I did not think
about that yeah I I can see I can see
that that that Harry is the Dumber boys
don't had to bring two pairs of gloves
[Laughter]
you're right I can see there the dumber
weave up their duo conclusively decided
that Lloyd is dumb yeah cannon you heard
it here first
alright keep going I've made the Whitney
now they explode with rage whenever
they're outsmarting
haven't sold time on a bust explode dad
they're up against Howard Payne one of
the great phone-based villains of the
90s attention now Dennis Hopper thrills
as the Joker without the makeup in such
a convincing madman performance you
won't even question why he holds the
phone all weird sure a bomb injured his
left hand but it made his right ear go
deaf next you're gonna tell me cars
don't fly talk about the hand thing yeah
we'll stand by it pause I've always I've
wondered this from from the 11 year old
me happy that he could watch an r-rated
movie why does he hold the phone across
his body like this instead of just is it
because it's more interesting it looks
cool yeah I guess my bigger question is
why didn't it catch on you in the pain
when they answered the phone
you take your body up to hashtag pain
and you're training people Ryker got the
backwards seat yeah why didn't why
didn't the pain phone pick up maybe it's
because of all those other movies that
he saw Dennis Hopper saw his amount of
itch doing this one different and he's
like I'm doing this he's crazy
yeah I think that it was I don't know if
it was a quirk just to make him seem
more unpredictable like an engine but I
think that they heard it was just like a
script supervisor messing up because
obviously he was injured probably by a
bomb he worked on the bomb squad he had
burn scars but if you blow up your hand
explodes this year goes deaf not this
one listen he was doing this unless you
madman
if you think his ear would be do you
think it was that it could have been the
turn we see him on the phone before that
okay for cuz I'm like maybe that's just
how Dennis Hopper uses the phone and it
was like are you gonna tell Dennis
Hopper that's weird some kind of a phone
booth seen an Easy Rider race just like
hey man yeah we just never knew Lisa can
some intrepid viewer see if Dennis
hoppers use the phone yeah weird please
get back to us thank you
keep going very important to us
a bus full of people who either just
found out they're going to die or that's
just how everyone looks when they're on
a bus check this with famous bus patron
just off yeah Joe Danielle yes that's
how we look just resigned there's
literally like honestly it reminds me of
the same way when people like I wish you
guys would do some behind the scenes of
when you write your trailers and it's
like no we're all very quiet and we just
stare at our monitors like this movie
should be so quiet no matter what's
happening yeah because no one on it
unknown on public transit ever
acknowledges anything anything a a man
got on a bus in San Francisco with this
once and just dropped his pants started
peeing spinning around with his arms
outstretched and yelling helicopter and
no one said a word
no one even look at him surely they said
stop you don't get paid on this movie
should be so quiet
no banter no cheering no sadness when
that lady blows up just waiting for
their stuff the third one should know
why contact it's just the story of that
guy Sandra Bullock [ __ ] I had no lies I
had someone on the bus the other day try
to correct my posture there's like very
nice lady and I was like you trying to f
why are we talking right now
interesting well okay there you go yes
also a pre cell phone era so you had to
be more creative about not talking to
each other yeah that's sure yeah
interesting stuff but there you go bus
riders we did you justice that's what
you look like everyone looks when
they're on a bust I love the timing was
bringing her in a shot music Sandra
Bullock goes from that girl and
demolition man to a Mariners McCart all
things to Halle Berry for passing on the
role and Ellen DeGeneres - that would
have been weird
do you ever thanked me for your career
sandi paws I cannot picture that even
slightly not even though the guy can
picture Halle Berry yeah I cannot
picture Ellen DeGeneres unless you
completely rewrite the role and she's
just like goofy weirdo that's my
question is did they rewrite the role
once they cast injure Bullock because
Ellen Ellen like nineties Ellen like
quirky comedian Ellen would work for the
LA miss of it all but only if she were
just another camera and type kooky kind
of person on a bus but I don't know if I
could see the romance angle yeah the
comedy it was not mr. roster wrong yeah
the dark what's his name Keanu was
supposed to be more of a traditional
like spouting one-liners more like macho
type character and Halle Berry was
supposed to be a ambulance driver like a
like a paramedic or something like that
who happened to be on the bus so like it
would make sense why she would drive the
bus real good but the screenwriter
wanted somebody to play off of Keanu's
like gung ho alpha dog seriousness like
to be the comic relief to be like his
wisecracking sidekick but I think that
Joss was like no let's play the realism
of this was quick bus yeah this movie
was one of the ones that's like was
being rewritten like the subway stuff is
all a late-stage rewrite that's a
perfect yeah yeah they're supposed to be
like driving around the like the
Hollywood sign or the whole film so yeah
lots of rewrites can't get up there five
miles an hour no he can't even walk up
there but if you but imagine it jumping
on its I'm just catching it and just
they do like an old history right where
Hollywood land is still there and the
bus is what knocks over land
thumbin Louise it just freeze frames yes
into that yeah yeah or a narrator comes
on he's like that Keanu sure is in
trouble
cute guy as a woman who does her best to
keep the bus above 50 while keeping the
chemistry above zero with the human
equivalent of a sin rock garden I don't
care what the speedometer says there's
no way the bus is doing more than 30
tops and I'm so much smarter than this
which we saw the OJ chase that's about
30 goal sex this film is all about the
action and you know things are gonna go
fast but when things get in the way of
going fast it's worth only not Phillips
should go faster everything is any of
this possible
no but also shut up this is speed not
gravity
[Music]
out of context that was done yes context
that was like wow so right along for a
simple action Buster Posey just plain
works thanks to its likeable stars
snappy dialogue from an uncredited Joss
Whedon we're at the airport yeah so I
already seen the airport and a building
release of tension that's so masterful
even the victims on the bus are caught
up in the foot in there the audience
there the Greek gonna die and even if
you don't you're still on a bus we might
return to this music cue in the picture
that's better
starring John quick Dennis the Menace
bird bus sometimes I doubt your
commitment to spark emotion hopefully
get the diagnosis moves pretty fast if
you stop and look around once in a while
you'll explode feelers 90s dancing
whatever Joe lets us play the Dumb and
Dumber diarrhea quit yeah
[Music]
pause give the man an Oscar come to
suggesting this based off of an old SML
sketch barley show chris farley show
Jeff Dean was it the Chris Farley show I
think it might have been a different
sketch because I just remember Jeff
Davis and Inside the Actors Studio
scientist to do things kept playing they
would end they would queue up the clip
and they'd be like let's talk about star
man I think we have a close like I'm
sorry here's a clip of Jeff Daniels from
The Fabulous Baker boys didn't that
really happen as a news blooper somebody
who was like I quit or or as a genuine
mistake that that showed up on CNN or
something like it works anytime anywhere
but I personally keep suggesting it
because that is yet another you were
talking Spence about how you don't know
where the where your The Simpsons quotes
and and your yes I don't know where SNL
sketches band in my sense of humor
begins because that's one of my favorite
lost as enough to catch it so yeah
credit where credit is due so we're
gonna have to go to court like Conan
ideation from that bit in suggesting the
Dumb and Dumber - well I think there's
never a bad time it always plays really
no matter did no never
literally never yeah it's our new Alan
that's a triple DC yeah oh wait endgame
spoilers go away till the trailer for
infinity war so yeah people in the staff
did return yeah but so you know they've
changed
that's true yeah we'll see now is
dinosaur friends are older
keep coming
[Music]
mr. Lowe's Wild Ride
Interactive TV jack wave of the future
it's called YouTube mr. hopper and
you're on it that stupid gag now let's
see some deleted scenes roll right in
elephant never sure a bomb injured his
left hand but it made his right ear go
deaf I think it's just cuz he's crazy
porky polar crazy child center okay
eccentric whatever hops while keeping
the chemistry above zero with a human
equivalent of a sin rock garden why
would they even talk about probably gum
fuzz I heard a theory that the reason
Keanu Reeves is a popular actor is
because he has such a blank expression
on his face that he's like answer like a
stick figure that people can easily
implant themselves just the basis of
keyattr
he's just calling by being like an
emotive he's like a like a blank slate
that you can then become the protagonist
more easily I think there's like a charm
to his Zenoss mm-hmm yeah I think he's
just a likable guy yeah he's not he's
often not a particularly strong actor
and yet he's had great success and I
think people root for him because it's
like here's a guy maybe sometimes a
little out of his depth and yet I don't
like him yeah just sheer charisma yeah
also very attractive I mean I feel like
we can't discount that that's perfectly
attractive he's great in the John wick
movies yeah yeah he's really like
legitimately good but I do think that
detached or cool characters play to his
strengths yes more so than the more
gutsy involved character moments like
the railers the rage stuff even in this
movie is he's great is Ted like like not
like oh it's just being himself like no
he's got good comic timing yeah
good like the scene where he's just like
there's everything I learned in class
like Napoleon Joan of Arc and Socratic
method like like he's obviously scanning
the board behind when they didn't
Telegraph every joke and that it would
just come to a thing that like a
close-up of Socratic methods and show
you that that like because people think
he's doing it taking base Keanu and then
adding one or two things on top of it to
make a character like even neo is like
base Keanu plus overwhelmed and in all
yeah what's happening around him it's an
open-face key under sandwich yeah
exactly yeah I'm on base can of bread
little meat little lettuce yeah who
doesn't like a sandwich
he got chewed up and spit out everyone
laughed at him like this is post Dracula
where everybody laughed at him everyone
laughed at Keanu and said that he sucked
it was awful and he couldn't act and
what did he do he came out and made
point braced surprise action movies of
all time like in 94 and then Point Break
was like a year before maybe - well yeah
but I think I want to say Jackie it was
after Point Break oh yeah like post
Dracula's like he'll he's a
laughingstock and he came out he did
this movie and it was great everyone
loved it and they're like Keanu they
came for him I root for him yeah he's
gonna speed it up he's my Johnny man
mnemonic yeah always will be Johnny
action yeah right and keep coming right
under motorcycle jack in the bus
juhi point no brakes not so easy
brighter at the Muni bomber says there's
a POW who has one thumb and loves
explosions this guy he sandy driver baby
driver demolition woman
and he get your gum the fuse room and
he'll keep bombing me he'll keep bombing
me you'll make me feel guilty
this is ridiculous okay I'll pay I'll
pay I'll pay it's a very long and joke I
just want to see it in the tools
anything else no that's it guys well we
did it did we keep this commentary over
50 words per minute or else it'll
explode I think we did I think they
pulled it off we jumped the track yeah
yeah quick keep Tug is there anything
else you wanna say about speeds mention
the score also interchangeable with
every other movie from the 1994 to 2001
really yes that's Armageddon and then
dun dun that's part of the Caribbean and
that's the same composer it's just that
that's the board's who as it was in the
nineteen oh man I've never seen speed to
cruise control
neither of I never saw happening I saw
it in theaters Wow it was a light
Danielle paint a picture um you know how
you're supposed to keep things above a
certain miles per hour
it felt like it was well well below
those sure sure it was a sandy Bullock
tried her hardest
Jason Patrick was also there yeah does
she ever turn to the camera and go not
this again basically but then it's a
nautical pun cuz not sir
yeah yeah no basically she almost Jim
faces but not quite yeah
Tim's very close to Jim it's my favorite
parts of die hard - how come you should
ever the same guy twice is gonna say it
otherwise yeah yeah well well we'll give
that a rewatch or first watch and this
is off camera next time can we use does
the thing I guess this is presumably for
blockbuster summer or John wick 3d both
I'm sure like what you did John wick
this is way more fun for us than a
trailer project maybe the Austral John
wick - it's an action is pretty cool
don't really care much for the
assassination the hightail economy where
the tailings pigeon secret army like
just kill the dog have them kill
everyone else company that's my own
company ground versus ice cream cake
Otto starring this is so much fun I know
John we're going to would probably have
gotten us to chapter 2 whatever we'll
probably we got miss more views but this
is so much more fun yeah yes yeah we'll
all be saying that on the streets but
Thomas a year yeah but we had more fun
too bad the here's the other point I'll
make the angelic - is there ever like
awkward misunderstandings when he's
talking to like the sommelier and stuff
like that where he's like and how about
a merlot or whatever it's like oh no I
meant a gun gun sir oh we're all talking
in code still oh no I'm like is there
really a one-to-one thing for like every
silencer or every like little like coat
the tailor and stuff like that
there's a lot of assassin training goes
into subtle lingo I think the
miscommunication is the point of asking
for the small yay where someone goes I
need to speak to your sommelier versus
someone who's like I need to speak to
Somalia and and someone misunderstanding
that it's sending them to the gun person
with a bottle of wine
one moment sir that's where he comes in
yeah John wick - what else that's good
movie good what else what else
splash slash yeah like a good choice to
Ruby Rose meat that she women xxx
yeah after xxx 5 return of Sanders rage
girls in again but she looks good the
bat costume so that's been honest
trailer commentaries you're not stupid
babies if you made it through this far
you should know by now that was a
Simpsons reference and we'll see you
next week for something pretty epic yeah
yeah because we get on this show and
this franchise and it's not epic movie
you're welcome
see you that
[Music]
you